let us now abstract from a previous
example and provide a general definition
of for the discrete-time finite state
Markov chain is first central in the
description of a Markov process is the
concept of a state which describes the
current situation of the system we are
interested in for example in the case of
the checkout counter example the number
of customers in the queue provided the
right level of information needed to
define a useful state time is assumed to
be discrete that is divided in discrete
time steps the system starts at time
zero in an initial state and at each
successive time steps the system goes
from its current state to a next one
chosen with some randomness as a result
after n such transitions the state of
the system will be random and so we can
think of it as a random variable lets xn
this random variable that is xn
represents the state in which the system
is after n transitions from an initial
state in which it started to operate as
a shortcut we may often say that xn is
the state of the system at time n we
suppose that there is a finite number of
possible states for the system to be in
here we have drawn a portion of a finite
state space with M possible States
labeled 1 to M using I and J as generate
labels of course we could think of
systems with an infinite number of
states either discrete or continuous but
this is a bit more complicated and so in
this course we restrict ourselves to a
finite state space note that the initial
State
could itself be fixed or chosen randomly
assume now that the system started in
state 3 what will happen next the system
will evolve according to one of the
possible transitions out of state 3 for
example one of these arcs note here that
we don't have an arc from 3 to 4 as a
convention we only include arcs for
transitions that can happen
remember the checkout counter example
because of our assumptions that no more
than one person can join the queue at
any time within an arcs of the type
going from 1 to 3 or from 2 to 10 also
because of the customer is being served
one at a time
departures were limited to one person at
a time and so no arcs of the type going
from 2 to 0 or from 9 to 2 so the next
transition out of 3 can be thought of a
random jump where from state 3 the
system will jump to either state 1 state
to state J or jump unto itself
these will be the only possibilities we
want to describe the statistics of these
jumps and we will use conditional
probabilities given that at time 0 the
system is in state 3 what is the
probability that it will be in state J
next these will be called transition
probabilities for example the priority
of going 4 3 2 1 4 B P 3 1 here P 3 2
here
and here P 3j note that these are the
only possibilities as a result you have
P 3 1 plus P 3 2 plus P 3 3 plus 3 J
will be 1
assume that the system continued to
evolve and after various different steps
come back in 3 at time n again what will
happen next
while this property here says that the
probability of going from state 3 to 1
is again P 3 1 the same as before in
other words here we will say that the
chain is time ma genius that is these
transition probabilities will be the
same irrespective of the time so this is
true for all N and the summation that we
have written here for this special case
is of course general what we have is
that the priority of I J if you sum all
of these probabilities for all possible
J's you will have 1
now in order for this probabilistic
specification to make sense and be
coherent we need to make a big
assumption about the evolution of the
state of the system this assumption the
so called Markov property given in words
here and in mathematical statement here
is in fact the defining nature of what a
Markov process is in words what it says
is that every time the system finds
itself in state 3 the transition
probability of going to state 1 will
always be p3 1 no matter how the system
evolved in the past up to being in state
3 in other words no matter what path the
system has followed up to the current
state the next state transition priority
will be the same independent of that
past mathematically conditionally on
knowing your current state having more
information about the past state
variables does not change the transition
probability to your next state so in
other words the probability distribution
of the next state xn plus 1 depends on
the past only through the value of the
present state xn so you can see that as
a definition of the transition
probability and that property that
equality from here to here being the
Markov property for this property to old
in any modeling application you need to
choose your state carefully you want to
ensure that the information contained in
the description of your state captures
all the relevant information to make
prediction about the future evolution
now given a system how to properly
define the state variables which will
allow us to model the its evolution as a
Markov process is somewhat of an art and
there are no cookbook recipes to do it
however with a little bit of experience
and practice one quickly gets the
required intuitions to do this properly
you will be able to do so in that class